our next one is coming from a body Hinds
body hi body hi body shot to the chops
and gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz dog Brennan
Theo Chi boy Bodie here in Oklahoma City
coming actually with a king and esteem
mm-hmm
[ __ ] in public and I'm not talking
about I feel I'm not talking about going
on going in a bush and taking a [ __ ] or
on the side of the street
I'm talking about Walmart McDonald's all
that [ __ ] I'm saying like that for me I
can't do it I don't know what it is I
don't know if it's a toddler don't know
bro but anytime I go in and I can smell
the ass of the person before me
it's called [ __ ] called rubber rod can't
do it man so really should wait to see
what you guys have to say about it
all your podcast anytime they drop on
you know in my ear so I love you guys
appreciate what you guys are doing keep
it up and Gang Gang buzz buzz buzz Thank
You bear sorry nice guy Bodie and I
appreciate that and also Derek called
you body let's start there there bro how
does he spell it Bodh eye now I'm
regretting how I said it now ah
shouldn't in public restaurants we out
on this well look man it depends dude I
think if you can stand and do it there's
that kind of Polynesian kind of style
where you can like put your stand on the
sumo squat yeah if you can do that with
your feet on the things looks like a
frog yeah in Africa if you go to Africa
you go to South Africa they just have
like a hole in the rounding to squat
over pretty calm and chill but [ __ ]
Otto I wouldn't recommend [ __ ] in a
train station downtown Tucson or in any
Dunkin Donuts something got on the back
of my legs there from the toilet seat it
have one of those steel toilet seats
it's like the floor just turns into the
toys yeah don't you talk about there's
no and one yeah it's a whole the whole
building is this all the one the walls
turning into the floor turns into the
toilet turns into the devil this is
Asian bro
oh dude and there was um yeah
was a lot of Miss like mystic riding and
stuff on the wall but I got us some
severe burns on the back of my legs from
sitting like the type of dude that
writes on bathroom walls I've done that
know anyone who writes on bathroom walls
yeah bro people over time history
hieroglyphics
dude when you're on your own yeah I you
know sometimes you got a [ __ ] you got a
[ __ ] man I'm no doubt about that
I just gotta you know but I'm not scared
to do it what I'm saying I don't care
sometimes you got a little you know be a
little hesitant if you're [ __ ] in a
club if you're [ __ ] man KFC a Waffle
House a game like a UFC fight because
you might get in there with the wrong
crowd yeah and then under do this
this is tap and that means they down the
suck you off dropping turds and sucking
dick yeah there's certainly it's Morse
code
it's Morse code though for what I'm
trying to help you out tonight or cut
your mores form or what we nerds yeah
bro the favorite it's two foot it means
come to my stop it's one foot come I'll
come to yours
what is Morse code bro so I'm all I'm
saying if you're gonna drop trou in
public places know the rules bro
don't get mad when your dick skins suck
when you drop on low because if you
engage in that sort of you're out here
bremen how many dudes have tried to [ __ ]
you with a bunch yeah I'm fending them
off it's my training for the u.s. just
slapping dicks like this [ __ ] oh my
god you're going to hell live a little
man yeah well you're gonna be living in
hell bucko well I'd [ __ ] King shittin
on in public places
Bodie I gotta go you gotta go planes I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah oh I won't [ __ ]
on a plane and go my high dump I know
well what's up baby I know well enough
to [ __ ] before the plane leaves or then
or then defecate after the plane lands
I'm not one of those weirdos just cuz
I'm in the air for three hours means I
have to go defecate you know and I've
[ __ ] dude I used to [ __ ] out
and I used to bury this guy's [ __ ] for a
long time in his yard when I was a kid
if I'm flying spirit because it's so
insulting the shitty seats they give you
in service I just blow up those
bathrooms just for the [ __ ] of it Wow
yeah suck it spirit it's hard to in
South West for that matter I don't like
doing number twos in the air because it
just seems like it's just against God I
feel like it doesn't feel natural I'll
give you that yeah you shouldn't be
doing Dookie while you're flying at 300
miles an hour 300 in the air yeah
how fast do you think planes go this is
gonna be great 600 miles an hour Wow
unbelievable man we look it up
I bet it's four to four they just said
300 300 yeah and I might have not known
oh you were pretty close 500 seven mile
575 miles an hour oh wow
seems like someone has an education here
uh go on to the next one Wow King Jigme
here 11 episodes I'm gonna say king of
man also the big move is is doing that
uh that that that Clint Eastwood is when
you know door on the stall and you [ __ ]
at a place ooh that's you talk about
that country-western huh oh yeah see
again you're asking for trouble men
really yeah code no that's that frickin
old school that's that frickin Johnny
splash baby when you [ __ ] take the
door off a stall and take a dump there
John Wayne Wayne that's that wild boy
yeah that's that [ __ ] yeah
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching